algérie les me gagne les principales
villes du pays un premier bilan fait
état de près de 200 tués le gouvernement
reconnaît la gravité de la situation
premier reportage complet de nos envoyés
spéciaux dans alger où l'armée les
manifestants demeurent face à face le
pape jean paul ii à strasbourg dialogue
avec toutes les communautés religieuses
il s'adresse également aux européens
votre soif de biens matériels vous fait
oublier l'existence même de dieu tunnel
sous la manche de part et d'autre on
creuse pour tenir le pari rattachée
l'île la grande-bretagne à leur offre en
1993 dans ce journal la visite du plus
grand chantier du monde
côté anglais et français madame monsieur
bonsoir manifestations émeutes ces
termes sont aujourd'hui dépassés pour
qualifier les événements d'algérie et
sans que l'on puisse encore parler ce
soir de soulèvement général on peut
affirmer que l'agitation a gagné les
principales villes du pays et que la
réplique du gouvernement par
l'intermédiaire de l'armée a été très
dur
un premier bilan fait état de plus de
170 victimes depuis mardi dernier
c'est en fin d'après midi et la nuit que
malgré le couvre-feu
les accrochages les plus durs ont lieu
entre militaires et manifestants comme
en témoigne ce premier reportage
parvenue en france grâce aux envoyés
spéciaux d'antenne de jacques merlino et
jean cornu qui sont parvenus à se
faufiler dans les rues d'alger
la nuit dernière et ce matin regardez
alger samedi soir 10 heures
le couvre-feu est tout de suite de
longues rafales d'armes automatiques
dimanche matin les hélicoptères prennent
leurs rondes incessantes au dessus de la
capitale tandis que dans les rues se
consume les derniers restes des émeus
cette rue est située à bellecour un
quartier très populaire et entre deux
charges de police les enfants viennent
fouiller les décombres à la recherche de
ce qui peut être récupéré le centre
d'alger maintenant ce grand bâtiment qui
a entièrement brûlé était le ministère
de la jeunesse
il fut l'une des premières cibles des
manifestants des jeunes pour l'essentiel
qui prennent le risque à visage
découvert de nous expliquer leur révolte
la jeunesse a demandé ses droits il est
agréable c'est pas d'app agi à tour les
jeunes en tout cas ces gens tout cas
c'est oui mais pourquoi
c'est pas rien vous voyez une envie
quand elle n'avait pas besoin son sort
est un qui a rien le linge sale se lave
en famille la rue didouche mourad
l'une des artères les plus commerçantes
toutes les vitrines sont brisés encore
des voitures calcinées des voitures de
l'administration reconnaissables à leurs
plaques rouges et voici ce qui reste du
blue note
l'une des rares boîte de nuit d'alger
la police est omniprésente police
secrète mélangée la foule police urbaine
en uniforme forces anti-émeutes appelé
police noir et enfin l'armée elle est
partout mais il est strictement interdit
de la filmer et l'on ne peut saisir que
ces quelques images saisies à la volée
soldats tous les 5 mètres baïonnette au
canon des chargeurs garnis de balles
réelles
les chars sont postés à tous les
carrefours et protège tous les édifices
publics
ici le siège du fln aucun bilan officiel
du nombre des victimes n'a encore été
communiqué mais on peut estimer de
manière sérieuse et selon des sources
médicales que le nombre de morts par
balles alger et dans les autres villes
d'algérie est supérieur à 100 un bilan
qui peut encore s'alourdir puisque ces
dernières heures l'armée tire est encore
d'alger après ces réactions sur place
donc d'autres maintenant enregistré ce
matin à l'arrivée à orly du seul vol
alger paris autorisés à décoller ce
dimanche claude crespo vous avez
vous-même assistaient des mureaux et
ouais ouais bien sûr j'étais pris dans
les hôpitaux cia et patrick six pattes
car je me suis pris de la lacrymo dans
la figure et c'était assez violent
c'est terrible c'est à dire ben beyrouth
comme beyrouth la même chose ils tirent
à la mitraillette islam est dans les
rues ouais j'ai failli prendre une balle
moi même et qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement dans les rues par exemple
pour vous étrangers l'aller batailles de
rue on peut pas sortir entre qui entre
les jeunes et
les forces de l'ordre mais pas les crs
les militaires c'est terrible depuis
trois jours ainsi qu'une petite
révolution quoi mais une révolution avec
des morts bien sûr vous avez assisté
vous allez aimer dans les rues
automatiquement bien sûr je suis en
droit
entre qui et qui 20 maintenant c'est
entre le peuple et le gouvernement en
gouvernement maintenant c'est l'armée et
les policiers
voilà donc pour les réactions 100 morts
disait il ya quelques instants jacques
merino c'est un bilan partiel on parle
ce soir de plus de 170 victimes
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
compris et face à cette violence de la
rue qui ne supportent plus la crise
économique
attisé par les intégristes religieux le
pouvoir est bien obligé de reconnaître
la gravité des événements le président
de la république monsieur ben mhenni de
chadli doit s'adresser demain soir à la
population et déjà le ministre de
l'intérieur dans un message télévisé
hier soir a dû reconnaître
officiellement que l'agitation avait
gagné une bonne partie du pays
chaque merlino une déclaration la nuit
dernière la télévision le ministre de
l'intérieur a pour la première fois
reconnu que les troubles s'étendaient
sur le territoire nous savions en
actions précises sur le nombre de
victimes en dehors d'alger à oran la
ville de tiaret à 3,3 km à l'est d'alger
aurait connu un véritable carnage
alger au 5e jour du début des émeutes le
libre entre double visage calme le jour
terrible à nu qui sera car cet après
midi il est en rage unitaire ce renfort
et tout le monde attend une nouvelle
explosion de violence les comptages de
nuit dernière ont été terribles
un quartier de couvin rencontrer les
victimes qui dit ata d'el oued et un du
1er mai ces victimes et que bien souvent
sont des enfants entre 10 et 15 ans par
ailleurs quelque chose serait
catastrophique dans les hôpitaux où
s'entassent mort répétées et on commet
traite avant que de francs sur le plan
diplomatique le gouvernement français
n'a pas pris encore position
officiellement
en espagne où il se trouve aujourd'hui
le ministre des affaires étrangères
français monsieur roland dumas s'est
déclarée simplement et prudemment
d'ailleurs préoccuper monsieur dumas
j'ai indiqué que le gouvernement
français ceux occupés de l'évolution des
événements d'un jury je ne souhaite pas
des commentaires à celui que je sers
bien fier hier le si de nouveaux
développements interviennent les
examinerons je répète dans l'esprit que
j'ai décrit hier c'est à dire un esprit
de solidarité avec le peuple algérien
avec l'âge
avec ces autorités et enfin à paris ce
matin dans le quartier à majorité
algérienne du xviiie arrondissement au
métro barbès rochechouart plusieurs
centaines de manifestants ont défilé
puis sont restés groupés une partie de
l'après midi
exprimant leur soutien aux émeutiers
d'algérie parmi eux plusieurs leaders de
mouvements d'opposition au gouvernement
actuel du président chadli bendjedid
voilà donc pour ce dossier ce soir
l'actualité française de ce dimanche
c'est d'abord le pari des nîmois dont la
ville a été dévastée mardi dernier par
un torrent de boue et qui se sont promis
juré même d'effacer les dernières traces
de cette catastrophe avant ce soir
minuit pour que tout redémarre
normalement demain lundi henri bodiguel
françois ya dans cette ville où
l'activité économique était un homme
depuis une semaine les services
techniques sont pas l'oeuvre 24 heures
sur 24
près de 800 véhicules 4500 hommes
pompiers militaires sécurité civile
bénévoles une formidable machine dont le
moteur principal a été la solidarité
l'entr'aide de tous pour permettre à
chacun de retrouver demain une ville et
une vie presque normale lundi matin la
ville de tournus je pourrais citer
quelques exemples significatifs
l'ensemble des établissements scolaires
où l'animateur le réseau de transports
fonctionnent normalement qu'à semaine
normalement lundi matin
en ce qui concerne maintenant
les problèmes de circulation ils sont
pratiquement réglé à ce qui concerne
l'eau potable sur 130 mille pertes
personnes il nous reste et il y a dix
minutes 500 personnes a alimenté d'une
manière normale et je pense que demain
matin la totalité du réseau d'eau
potable david de nîmes sera rétabli
alors les peaux noires les points noirs
les plus serviles sont ceux qui sont
directement liés à l'origine de la faire
c'est à dire à l'écoulement des eaux
pluviales
cardona les 97 écoles maternelles et
primaires ainsi que les 21 collèges ces
établissements secondaires seront à
nouveau en mesure d'accueillir les
élèves
l'eau est désormais potable dans tous
les quartiers tout juste est elle un peu
plus coloré que la normale 87 familles
sur 105 ont déjà été relogées soit dans
les hlm de la ville soit chez des
particuliers ou dans des appartements
prêtés par des agences immobilières
votre soif de biens matériels vous
détournent de dieu c'est ce que le pape
jean paul ii a dit aujourd'hui dans le
serment qu'il a prononcé à strasbourg au
matin de son deuxième jour de voyage en
france durant lequel il a également
rencontré les principaux représentants
des communautés religieuses d'alsace et
de lorraine journée qui se termine ce
soir par la célébration du 2000ème deux
millième anniversaire de la naissance de
la ville de strasbourg françois corner
daniel lévy cette poignée de main entre
le pasteur fait lé président des églises
protestantes d'alsace et jean paul 2 est
incontestablement le geste le plus
important de cette journée le
protestantisme en alsace lorraine
constitue sensiblement 30% de l'ensemble
de la population de la région
la présence en ce dimanche du chef de
l'église catholique à l'église
saint-thomas de strasbourg est donc un
événement cette église étant le symbole
du protestantisme en alsace lorraine
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas aussi un jour
une telle communion avec vous les
catholiques puisque lettres en christ
nous est offert aux uns et aux autres
un signe de ce rapprochement à
strasbourg et de la marche vers l'unité
des chrétiens
une bible latine du xviie imprimé en
alsace offert au pape par l'église
protestante
autre moment émouvant le dialogue ce
soir du pape avec la communauté
israélite à l'évêché de strasbourg
un événement dont la communauté juive a
voulu exprimer toute la portée
en rappelant ce qu'elle doit au
catholicisme alsacien notamment lors de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
dans cet effondrement de l'europe
le pelage est du pays où nous vivons
c'est conquis des titres inoubliables à
notre reconnaissance
comment nier ou passés sous silence
l'esprit de sacrifice de tant d'hommes
dont au cours de ces années terribles
nous fûmes les obliger ouverture
renouvelé au dialogue avec les
protestants condamnation de
l'antisémitisme
la deuxième journée de jean paul ii à
strasbourg aura revêt une grande
importance puisqu'elle englobe désormais
tous les courants spirituels présent en
alsace lorraine des barbelés dernière
étape de cette journée pour jean-paul de
la cathédrale pour les fêtes du
bimillénaire de strasbourg
ce soir donc sur le parvis de la
cathédrale de strasbourg célébration du
2000ème anniversaire de la naissance de
la ville alsacienne
nous retrouvons sur ce parvis jean
claude d'arrigo jean club
oui oui daniel puis ce n'est pas par
hasard si les célébrations du
bimillénaire de strasbourg se déroule en
ce moment aux alentours de la cathédrale
de la capitale alsacienne
cet édifice est le symbole de richesse
culturelle et spirituelle de ce coin de
france qui depuis lé de milan a été le
théâtre et le carrefour des joies et des
tensions de l'europe occidentale
deux mille ans de vie en continuité peu
de cités peuvent s'enorgueillir d'avoir
des racines aussi ancien
ce fut d'abord argento ratou mais ses
légions romaines puis après un saut dans
l'histoire en 842 le fameux document
serment de strasbourg
le premier document rédigé conjointement
en langue germanique et en langue romane
à strasbourg on le sait gutenberg a
perfectionné son invention de
l'imprimerie à strasbourg calvin a
déployé une partie importante de son
activité et goethe a trouvé ici un
milieu favorable au développement de sa
pensée alors strasbourg un résumé une
synthèse de vingt siècles de vie dont on
retrouve les traces pratiquement à tous
les endroits de cette ville mais
notoirement au pied de cette cathédrale
que jean paul ii au nord ce soir de sa
visite pour cette fête à la fois
religieuse et profane
la semaine sociale en france maintenant
une semaine qui s'annonce agitée avec le
conflit aux usines renault une grève aux
ateliers du mans qui fabrique les pièces
détachées bloque en effet la production
de toute la régie mais c'est surtout du
côté des infirmières que le conflit se
durcit en marge des syndicats officiels
qui reprennent demain la négociation la
coordination nationale des infirmiers
rappelle un mot d'ordre de grève
reconductible de 24 heures en 24 heures
et cela à partir de demain lundi
à ce propos justement le président de la
république monsieur mitterrand a estimé
aujourd'hui qu'on ne pouvait pas régler
ce problème en quelques mois alors
qu'ils étaient posés depuis plusieurs
années maintenant monsieur mitterrand
aussi justifié que ce soit un mouvement
qui tente à restituer et pouvoir d'achat
et moyens de vire et organisation du
travail et temps de vivre et dignité
autant ne peut pas demander à un
gouvernement en l'espace de quelques
mois de réparer ce qui n'a pas été fait
pendant ces décennies et qu'aucun budget
national ne peut absorber en une fois et
en l'espace de quelques mois ce qui est
exigera un plan de quelques années
encore faudrait-il encore faudra-t-il
que ce quoi que ce plan soit mise en
place
ça c'est la responsabilité de diamants
de ce gouvernement comme des autres j'y
veillerai croyez-moi ou moins sérieux
mais que le conflit des infirmières mais
ennuyeux pour les milliers de touristes
qui sont encore dans la capitale en
cette période de l'année
les employés de la tour eiffel le
monument le plus visité de paris et même
du monde sont en grève les ascenseurs
sont arrêtés restent les escaliers
elisabeth sd la tour eiffel est fermée
depuis hier matin pour tous même ceux
venus de loin pas d'ascenseur ni même
d'escalier accessible pour les plus
courageux parfois venus en groupe
c'est du personnel communal de la ville
d'aïn bec et nous pensent se monte à la
droite peine tout le monde est déçu de
ne pas pouvoir monter sur les 140
personnes employées par la tour eiffel
une centaine est en grève les liftier et
vendeurs de billets leurs revendications
sont salariales
actuellement notre taux ita bat francs
0,5
donc les spiritueux c'est pour ça que
nous avons dit que nous avons fait cela
on fait cette grève
en fait nous demandons une augmentation
de 2 francs selon la direction les plus
bas salaires atteignent 133 1000 francs
par an grâce aux primes liées à la
fréquentation de la tour où se sont
rendus les quinze mille touristes prévue
aujourd'hui
le centre pompidou numéro un des
monuments visités en france à peut-être
battu un record
la politique maintenant le rpr hésite
toujours entre le oui le nom et où
l'abstention référendum sur la nouvelle
calédonie
exemple de cette hésitation la
déclaration d'alain juppé aujourd'hui il
faut parfois du courage pour refuser
d'entrer dans le piège at-il dit piège
tendu bien entendu par les socialistes
le selon le rpr et le secrétaire général
du mouvement gaulliste de s'interroger
notamment sur le fait que tous les
citoyens de nouvelle calédonie ne
pourront pas voter en 1998 et si l'on
faisait la même chose demain pour la
corse a ajouté monsieur juppé fait
divers tragique un enfant de 13 ans tuée
par une balle perdue dans une cité de
noisy-le-sec dans la banlieue parisienne
cette jeune fille se trouvait sur son
balcon observant une bagarre qui avait
lieu au bas de son immeuble
l'un des hommes qui se battaient a
soudain sorti une arme et tiré en l'air
pour intimider ses adversaires blessant
mortellement
la jeune fille des nouvelles du plus
grand chantier du monde le tunnel sous
la manche qui fut longtemps un serpent
de mer est aujourd'hui une réalité
de part et d'autre on creuse avec des
moyens matériels exceptionnelle et
spectaculaire pour tenir le pari lancé
rattacher la grande bretagne à l'europe
en 1993 jacques violet et mes maillots
côté français un puits gigantesque 60
mètres de large
cinquante de profondeur d'où partent les
tunnels terrassement et aux technologies
en surface on prépare les terrains pour
les gares les terminaux sur 800 hectares
un ballet ininterrompu d'engins en tout
genre de chaque côté de la manche sur
chaque chantier
deux mille personnes on creuse trois
tunnels un tunnel de service et deux
pour les trains on va donc creuser trois
fois 50 km soit 150 kilomètres de
galeries comme on ne pouvait pas viser
directement pour situer les entrées des
tunnels on a utilisé un satellite
les signaux émis par le satellite ont
donné des coordonnées longitude et
latitude de deux points terrestre ces
relevés ont permis ensuite de déterminer
avec précision les deux entrées l'une
par rapport à l'autre haute technologie
également à l'intérieur des tunnels la
direction du forage est donné par une
visée laser travailler j'avais ici
consiste à mettre en place un rayon la
terre pour quitter le tunnelier
interdiction d'angleterre et pour
rejoindre collègues britanniques à une
précision de quelques centimètres pour
creuser on a dû concevoir et fabriquer
ces énormes machines des tunneliers
descendu en pièces détachées et assemblé
au fond il y en aura cinq en service en
france et 6 en angleterre il coûte
environ 150 millions pièce un train
technique une usine de 300 mètres de
long avec ses moteurs son alimentation
propre en tête de ce train qui avance
sur rails une énorme fraises qui coupe
la roche entre dedans c'est le diamètre
du tunnel lui met 80
cette phrase ne pourra pas reculer elle
sera découpé au chalumeau à la fin
derrière la machine évacue la terre
l'eau les boues et pose automatiquement
les anneaux de béton préfabriqué tout en
avançant en prenant appui sur le béton
déjà posé un mètre soixante à la fois
il sera fabriqué deux cent cinquante
mille éléments côté français tous
numérotés avec leurs joints de
caoutchouc
côté français le début des travaux
s'effectuent dans la craie blanche avec
beaucoup de difficultés les âmes ont les
pieds dans l'eau dans la boue les
machines travaillent souvent comme des
sous marins malgré ces difficultés on a
déjà creusé un kilomètre et les retards
seront rattrapés côté français nous
avons des conditions géologiques plus
difficile qui nécessite une mise au
point plus délicate des machines que
sont les foreuses
et tout ça va se résoudre pour l'instant
il n'est pas question de remettre en
question la date d'ouverture de mise en
place du système c'est-à-dire le 15 mai
côté anglais la roche sous les falaises
est meilleur on creuse directement dans
la craie bleue imperméables ou sera le
tunnel les véhicules roulent au ces on a
percé trois kilomètres n'y a pas de
retard côté anglais sauf un petit
interflora le tunnel de service qui est
d'environ cinq ou six semaines ça ça
c'est tout à fait vrai comparables 1 km
en france 3 en angleterre 4 kilomètres
seulement sur 150 qui reste à creuser
les machines doivent prendre leur rythme
de croisière accéléré il ne reste que
quatre ans et demi pour que ces falaises
que l'on aperçoit ici depuis la france
ne soit plus une île pour que la route
ne se termine plus sur la plage et
résultat du match donc dans quatre ans
et demi la décentralisation le mot à la
mode dans la france des années 90 ce qui
est vrai pour l'administration il est
également pour les salons paris vous
savez est engorgé de réunions de congrès
de conventions d'exposition en tout
genre lille est donc venu aux
organisateurs du salon de la décoration
de prendre la route de tours jean pesio
yanncik l objet contemporain confronté à
tours et à la touraine
ou le choc de la france profonde et de
la modernité
tel est l'enjeu de crest a cité la
première grande manifestation régionale
de design une partie des commerçants rue
nationale lui ont ouvert leurs vitrines
d'autres en nombre égal ou pour
l'instant refusé le pari en tout cas
commence dans les rues sur lesquels le
sculpteur oréfice fait flotter des
voiles de couleurs
il paraît que nous sommes assez
bourgeois est effectivement
on est un peu renfermé il faut beaucoup
de temps pour concevoir pour ouvrir les
tourangeaux design rien de tel que le
château le parisien de croix il montre
un plateau en matériaux composites et
inox
le tourangeau auto des glaces faussement
brisé
oh
cette chapelle offre à jean michel
wilmotte l'un des designers de l'elysée
le cadre rêvé pour ses meubles en verre
et métal sombre maître mot la rigueur
l'insertion d'un pont dans un sip
requérir designers ainsi jean-yves baril
avec le viaduc du tgv sur la loire le
premier pont sncf qui osent afficher la
couleur est l'élément contemporain doit
être beau mais il doit être également
pratique
alors si c'est un objet doit être bien
conçu et si c'est un hub confortable
confortable les fauteuils oui mais ce
jeune visiteur benjamin leur trouve
d'autres qualités
surtout quand les créateurs ont choisi
l'humour pour les mettre en scène
reconnaissez que sur ce point ils ont
avec benjamin à merveille aux complices
rêvons un peu et pour cela il faut
d'abord un décor le rocher des
milliardaires de monte carl avec une
vente aux enchères hors du commun
23 ferrari de collection construite
entre 1955 et 1970
la vente a atteint des records 92
millions de francs pour les vagues pour
les 18 voitures vendues les acheteurs
sont australiens japonais amérique et
pour vous donner un exemple la première
voiture que vous allez apercevoir dans
le reportage qui suit est une ferrari
jaune
elle a été mise à prix 2 millions de
francs elle s'est vendue plus du double
4 millions 4 exactement
thierry calmette et claude sicard
regardez
à
le marteau d'ivoire va libérer 300
chevaux adjugé 275 gtb 4 une ferrari
exceptionnellement jaune en 66 260
km/heure sur route et sur circuit
deuxième aux 24 heures du mans mais
cette berline est ce qu on dit aussi de
manière civilisée
sauvage la 250 gt compétition 76
exemplaires seulement adjugé 9 millions
de francs dessinée par pininfarina la
bière préférée d'enzo ferrari
toutes ces merveilles évoque la vitesse
même à l'arrêt comme des fellahs
ou des squales concédant même allé voir
respirer
à
le délire à 320 kilomètres heure et
trois places frontal le pilote assis au
milieu c'était la voiture de giovanni
agnelli le patron de fiat
un cavaillonnais âgés de plus de 20 ans
allons faire un tour
l'élégance des formes n'est pas
uniquement destiné aux magazines de mode
les douze cylindres vous propulse à plus
de 250 à l'heure l'âge d'or de la
compétition
la barquette 375000 son palmarès entre
1954 et 56 rempli deux pages de
catalogue exposés comme une oeuvre d'art
est vendu comme une oeuvre d'art
ces automobiles témoigne d'une époque
révolue
sans limitation de vitesse ni
d'imagination
enzo ferrari a disparu ces créations
continue de nous faire rêver
oui puisque nous sommes dans la folie un
record à ne pas imiter cet après midi
sur le tremplin olympique de ski de
saint nizier près de grenoble le motard
alain prieur a battu le record du monde
de saut à moto comme son nom l'indiqué
84 m avant de nous quitter et de vous
rappeler les résultats du tiercé nous
allons revenir un instant sur les
événements d'algérie vous savez qu'à 20
heures la télévision algérienne émet un
bulletin d'information ce soir ce
bulletin fait état d'un officiellement
du moins dans une certaine forme de
retour au calme jean marc qui nous a
écouté et regardé ce butin voici ce qui
en a tiré écoutons le et à l'ouverture à
l'instance du journal de 20h de la
télévision algérienne sur l' annonce
d'un discours du président chef d le
chef de l'armée et le patron du parti
unique du fln à la star leur à demain
pour la première fois en croire le
présentateur du journal de la télévision
d'état algérienne
le calme est revenu aujourd'hui à alger
ou fonctionnaires et travailleurs ont
repris le travail
information assorti d'un appel à rebâtir
l'algérie avec le sens du devoir
national
fin de citation à quoi servent les
destructions des vandales des le
présentateur sans désigner nommément des
responsables
retour au calme aussi à oran selon la
télévision officielle
sur ces images de marché approvisionner
on n'est toujours pas un mot sur le
nombre des victimes tant du côté des
forces de l'ordre que de celui des
nombreux civils tombés sous les balles à
alger comme dans le reste de l'algérie
pendant ces cinq jours d'émeutes
voilà donc ce que disais à l'instant
même en ce moment même la télévision
officielle algérienne mais rappelons
nous ce que disait tout à l'heure au
début de ce journal notre envoyé spécial
jacques merlino c'est en fin de soirée
et pendant la nuit que les émeutes et
les affrontements les plus durs ont eu
lieu tous ces jours derniers depuis
mardi date de début des événements en
alger voilà avant de nous quitter les
résultats du tiercé qui se courait cet
après midi vous allez les voir
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour gagner
les jouets le 12 le 5 et le 14 le
rapport que 750 francs pour ce qui
concerne le quarté vous ajoutez le 16 et
vous gagnez je vous le souhaite 6177
francs et 60 centimes voilà tout de
suite après journal la météo les
prévisions de josé blanc lapierre en fin
de programme c'est hervé claude qui vous
présentera le journal demain matin 7h45
télématin avec l' invité des 4 vérités
de gérard morin lionel stoléru le
secrétaire d'état chargé du plan et puis
demain soir ici même vous retrouverez à
20h christine ockrent je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée une excellente
semaine et je vous dis à samedi prochain
bonsoir
ah ah